first on CBS this morning a new report
says US schools are not doing enough to
protect students from drinking water
contaminated with lead the report found
quote a pattern of widespread
contamination of drinking water at
schools nationwide there's currently no
federal rule requiring schools to test
their drinking water for lead if they
get their water from a public water
system and a learner shows how one group
is pushing schools and the federal
government to take action and a good
warm morning good morning well just nine
states in Washington DC have mandatory
testing laws a government study last
year found only 43 percent of school
districts said they test for lead in
drinking water about a third of those
districts said they found elevated
levels of lead and many parents likely
have no idea their children may be
drinking it in her Boston home Julie MA
preps water bottles for her five and
six-year-old daughters to take to school
the next day their elementary schools
water fountains were turned off due to
lead contamination yeah I gotten a
letter from the superintendent saying
that her school was one of the schools
that tested above the 15 parts per
billion and that as a precaution they
were turning up all water fountains even
though it was only one fountain that was
tested that was three years ago since
then the district has brought in bottled
water for students to drink it's
concerning I really would like to get
the lead out of the the water supply as
fast as possible for the students many
schools don't even know if they have it
and haven't been able to make those
changes she's right
a new review of school drinking water
standards in thirty-one states and the
District of Columbia finds regulations
in most states are too weak to protect
children from lead contamination in
their school's water john rumbler
co-authored the report of the 32 states
including the District of Columbia that
we surveyed 22 of them are failing to
protect their kids from lead and
drinking water
22 correct the problem the group says
it's the fixtures fountains faucets and
other parts that contain lead the report
cites an Ohio school drinking fountain
that had more than
one hundred times the EPA's lead action
level for tap water
an Illinois school at 212 times that
level and one drinking fountain at a
Massachusetts school with nearly 1500
times the lead action level all of those
have been replaced but the group is
pushing for all schools to simply get
the lead out by replacing fixtures or at
a minimum installing and maintaining
filters on every faucet or fountain used
for cooking and drinking do you not
think that some school districts are
going to say look we're pressed for
funds as it is how are we gonna do that
first not every solution is going to
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars so
filters are you know $100 $200 some of
them are even less so that's a low cost
solution but you're absolutely right at
the end of the day not all communities
are going to be able to tackle this
problem on their own and that's why
we're excited to see states that are
stepping up and showing leadership in
helping communities invest in reducing
this problem but rumbler says the
federal government needs to step up to
with more funding and a stricter
standard for lead since children's
health experts agree that no amount of
lead is safe for children on wednesday
epa administrator andrew wheeler told
CBS News he plans to update drinking
water regulations regulation that hasn't
been updated in over 20 years and this
is a proposal that we're going to be
putting out this summer that I think is
going to help a lot of areas make sure
and ensure the public that they have
safe drinking life Wheeler says as part
of that the EPA will look at the
possibility of requiring testing for
school drinking water now if you're a
parent and you want information about
your child's school you'll have to reach
out to your school district again
pediatric experts say there is no safe
level of lead exposure for children it
impacts their growth and their learning
I think most parents would have thought
schools must test for lead right yeah I
think so too I think parents think that
just doesn't matter of course they're
gonna test the water and they're
actually after what we saw in Michigan
in Flint a brighter this would be a
national issue right and sometimes the
testings tricky too because just because
it's tested doesn't mean that there's no
lid
in it anybody talking about a database
the parents can go to to find out hey my
school was checked wouldn't that be a
great idea
yes and I don't think it exists anywhere
so far that's why they say never assume
it makes a blank out of blank and what